do you want no one leaves 90 troll and
everybody wants dijo the deed shows
without coming to LA Salaam alaikum
peace be with you thank you very much
for tuning in again to another episode
of the Dean show we're here every week
trying to help you understand it's not a
Muslim now you have come to that full
conviction that none has the right to be
worshipped except the one who created
you there's no god but God there is no
deity worthy of worship except Allah and
Muhammad is the last and final messenger
sent to mankind no more messages to come
and now this is not it there it needs to
be time spent learning this way of life
same way of life that was live with all
the messengers of God it's a complete
code of conduct a complete moral compass
that you go by from when you wake up
until you go to sleep so we're going to
be talking about mannerisms how we
conduct ourselves as those who have
submitted ourselves to the One God we
need to act a certain way we need to be
the elite in good etiquette and manners
and behavior and character this is
befitting a Muslim one who is
consciously submitted to the One God so
we're going to be talking about this
very very very important topic with our
next guest Sheikh Ibrahim is a damn when
we come back here an'desha we'll be
right back love there's only one
is his messenger Allah like in the world
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice Salaam
alaikum peace be with you Riley sit down
sheikh ibrahim zidane how are you doing
come to the left great hunter now we got
a lot and not yet Muslims non-muslims
out there who are listening to the show
and just so they don't think we shud
some cold words but you said it
hamdulillah what you say means praise be
to Allah the creator of the heavens in
here and some people might think oh
there they go Thomas a moon god right
who's Allah Allah the one the most
perfect the most high the almighty
nothing is the lack of him and he's the
all-hearer the all-seer and he's the one
that doesn't have a son or a daughter
he's nothing like the human beings and
he's the most merciful the one that is
over his creation over his throne and
with his creation with his knowledge and
his power and wisdom now before we get
into our topic we will talk about
manners etiquettes just just too we want
to sway Jenny fear because some people
might be tuning in for the first time
and they hear Islam and you know there's
some hype out there people believe you
know like you know Islam Muslim and what
comes next right muslim terrorist so you
know there's all sorts of you know
corruption out there but we know what
islam teaches and preaches but you got
you know some people who don't even want
to go further because they think oh
these people going to brainwash mean I
gotta strap a bomb to myself and go kill
innocent people what do we got to say
about this [ __ ] what we need to say is
that people need to think and make
decisions for themselves and not to
surrender their ideas and their opinions
based on just some people that has
certain agendas we have the religion of
Islam saved 1400 years ago the
revelation from Allah soprano tada
unlike the previous revelations where
human beings were entrusted with it when
it comes to Islam the the thing that was
revealed to the Prophet salah salem the
Quran and the Sunnah meaning his sayings
and his actions is all preserved in
every single detail so for every human
being to go back and see read the Quran
read the life of the profits of the
Lhari of Salem and find for yourself the
purpose
our life and you know been following the
truth this is our duty and one of the
sayings of the Prophet that he said that
he was sent to complete them to perfect
mannerism on the face of earth so we
have the perfect understanding of what
many reason is and we do not refer back
to our opinions or our desires or what
our environment would say it's all
referred back to the pure revelation
with verse after verse with hadith after
Harry the sayings of the Prophet peace
be upon him and it's all that all clear
but for people need to give the time and
learn it and get to apply themselves so
before we dwell into this so just for
the people who've had some negative
stereotypical views about Islam Islam
has nothing to do with hurting innocent
men women and chive had many people such
as sheikh waliba sunni absolutely not
there's actually a photo which is
grueling been issued by the senior scars
and so ready at 30 years ago before 911
before all these half society members
rahim allah they condemn these days i'm
decent specifically that it is forbidden
it is illegal there is nothing can
justify those that to specifically
mention hijacking airplanes attack in
urban areas as civilians and bombing
them dr. Bell office you know when 911
happened what did bush say bush was the
first one to get on the television and
say this is not an act of Islam this is
an act of a small band of terrorists you
know who are not acting according to
Islam because Islam means peace because
they say why don't you have the scholars
will condemn such actions the horn and
says don't kill women don't kill
children don't kill old people don't
attack the civilians this is what the
Prophet Muhammad told us innocent people
who are dying anywhere in the world life
is precious so but what is Islam clearly
it's Lama has nothing to do with any
acts of terrorism that's correct and
Islam there is no such a thing in Islam
as betraying one's trust and betray
people by deceiving them and killing
them by this by deception and betrayal
and all these types of things has
nothing to do with the religion of Islam
and people need to separate between what
Islam is the pure message from a lost
panel time and that if people do things
out of craziness or whatever there is
something that should not be related to
the dual message of it now the fog is
clear that junks out of the trunk and
you can relax now you swage any fear
we're talking about good old good stuff
and it starts off with the foundation of
worshipping the one who created you
alone without any partners not setting
up a partner next to got another guy
besides God but at the same time now
you've done that you acknowledge that
look I don't want to worship the
creation I want to worship the one who
created creation simple and I want to
obey the last and final message sent to
mankind and he said and we'll take it
from here didn't he say that I have not
been sent except to perfect good
mannerisms is this true toss worship
that's true that's correct and when we
see the statement somebody might say but
there are other rulings in the Quran and
the Sunnah the way of the Prophet not
just about mannerism so how that
statement means that I have a I was not
sent except to perfect the mannerism it
means that all of the religion of Islam
is all about mannerism how is that
mannerism is of three types there is
mannerism with Allah mannerism with the
messenger of allah mannerism with the
human beings mannerism what Allah beanie
meaning that if he's the one that
created us he's not that provided for us
that means worship Him alone imagine
someone that he hired you to do some
work a person going to a food place or
whatever there is and he works with him
and instead of wearing the t-shirt that
they gave him to wear with the logo of
the place he was something else and he
calls people to eat somewhere else
that's not been fulfilling the favors of
what he has in that place and to Allah
subhana Allah is the best example he
created and see provide for us he's the
only one worthy of worship the mannerism
would the Prophet peace be upon him that
Allah subhana Allah the most high sent
him for people to follow so we follow
his mannerism his actions all of his
affairs we need to humble ourselves and
to have the
mannerism with him we do not innovate in
the religion of al-islam do things that
the Prophet peace be upon him didn't do
because we're having the good manners
with him as a lot of the Most High
ordered us if people would do these to
the easiest part of mannerism is to have
the best mannerism with others we need
to have mannerism with our own selves
that we treat ourselves according to
what a lot of the Most High wants us to
treat it there are things in the
religion novel Islam in the Koran and in
the Sunnah of the Prophet peace be upon
him that teaches us how to deal with our
own selves how to deal with our wives
and the wife with the husband how to
deal with the children how to deal with
the friends with the enemies with the
neighbors if you are in a place where
anybody any relationship any variable in
our life and I'm not exaggerating and
this is something that people can go
back and see for themselves you will
find it in the Quran and in this one at
the way of the Prophet SAW Salem the
perfect way of life of having the best
mannerism deeds done by the heart thinks
to say how to speak how to act how to
look how to hear how to do any move in
our life based on a perfect way of life
of revelation of Allah now some Muslims
I mean we're all learning and we come
back from days of ignorance and we got
this roughness to us real rough you know
and now we feel that to be in Islam and
this is a misconception is it that now
some people feel like you know I'm not
being you know if I'm solved then you
know maybe something's wrong with me I
need to be this tough guy you know in
the religion but if we look to the last
and final messenger wasn't he the mercy
of mercies wasn't he teaching us
opposite of this right and Allah the
most high he said in the Quran feminity
min allahi lintel oh it is by the mercy
of Allah that you are lenient to them
lenient lenient to them and the time of
the Prophet ursuline before he was sent
the atoms at his time they were so
vicious in some of their acts that they
would kill their own daughters with
their own hands yeah what is more rough
than this and these same people a lot of
Most High changed them by the revelation
from a lot to be the most soft and the
most lenient and at the same time they
are firm when it comes to the orders of
Allah they do not compromise anything of
the religion
of allah the is at the wife of the
prophets are seldom she said that when
he was will be at home he will be in the
in the help of his family when he runs
the time for the seller comes as if we
do not know him I am not afraid to say
to me why did you become a Muslim no I
give a very frivolous on should i say i
want to be on the side of the angels
[ __ ] is a gar she's a number one rap
artists in the world he's sold over 60
million records worldwide steam million
Steve Miller he was a young guy we're
basically everything that somebody you
would think that life is all about he
had everything you can imagine Dean show
back here I'm the Dean show with sheikh
ibrahim sedan we're talking about
mannerisms is very important okay you
worship you go to the masjid but now you
act one way in the place of worship but
now you go outside of the masjid and you
might be lying stealing deceiving is
this what Islam is teaching us of course
not and the deficiency in this because
of the deficiency of how people make in
their prayers end up in the beginning of
the show you talked about a loss
panatela the Most High and how we
worship Him alone if this is perfected
everything else after that will be in
place and that's why if we have the
proper mannerism with a low and we stand
in the cellar and we look into the place
where we put our head in the Sudan the
frustration we recite certain things we
say certain things are we understanding
what we're saying is our hearts work
with what our tongue would be saying
when we humble ourselves and put our
head on the ground the head is the most
honoured part of our body and we put it
on the ground that for a human being but
for the creator of the heavens and earth
this has to do something with our heart
this is the humbleness that we're
supposed to carry with us outside the
sauna but most of us when we make the
prayers we just want to get something
done and leave we don't think of it we
don't have to say the proper humbleness
that's why the salad the players does
not have an effect in our life but in
which if we do it in the proper way if
we understand that we are slaves of the
creator of the heavens and the earth
then we would deal with people according
to what Allah wants from us so the
prayer is if it's done in the most
perfect way if you understand what we're
saying for fulfilled though that I hate
the oneness of worship of Allah purely
and perfectly then we'll treat each
other according to what Allah the most
high ones from us not according to what
we want with one another and this is
this is what we're like him isn't it
because we know that when the Muslims
when they went to was it Indonesia and
they had the best manners in business
many people when they saw the Muslims
how they were conducting themselves they
because they were used to this
corruption from them before but when
they embraced the religious the way of
life to complete submission to the one
guy and all the etiquettes and rules
that one has to follow now it
transformed them and people saw this the
not the non-muslim and they ended up
accepting Islam to this sure that's true
by the millions and Indonesia is the the
number one country of Muslims when it
comes to number-wise and it was not
opened with matters of the head it was
by basically trade and business and
things and this is manners this is
manners Wow and this is how the religion
of Islam spread actually is by the
mannerism that people didn't do it just
to deceive people to call them to the
religion it's the mannerism that the
most high the creator of heavens and
earth ordered them to act in a certain
way it one of the incidences that was
mentioning yesterday one of the early
generations of it is learned that many
of the Muslims do not know him his name
is Abdullah evening Mubarak he had a
Jewish neighborhood next to him yeah and
the Jewish neighbor was selling his
house and somebody came and he
system how much you selling the house
for he's a two thousand dinars whatever
the currency he said it's only worth
1,000 he said yes 1000 for the house and
once out 1000 for the neighborhood that
you're buying basically the neighbor
which is that man Abdullah bin Mubarak
so the neighbor was understanding that
this the mannerism of his neighbor was
worth money right so when Abdullah a new
robotic his neighbor know about this he
gave him a thousand and he told him keep
your house do you don't need to sell
your house he gave his money to the
Jewish neighbor to keep his house and
not to leave his house this is the
mannerism who were on the face of earth
would do this this was a Jewish neighbor
this is Jewish Wow right because he
thought that he's leaving because he is
in need of money so the neighbor is
taking care of his neighbor because this
is not something that is of goodness of
his own self this is the order of the
creator of the heavens in the earth that
you're not good unless you are good to
your neighbors and your neighbors if
they go sleep when they're hungry you
will be asked in the day of judgment why
did they go hungry when you are sleeping
full and not hungry this is
responsibilities that we have as Muslims
on the face of it so this is not only to
your brothers because is it true now the
we have brothers in faith but also we
have brothers in humanity that we want
to be our brothers in faith so we want
the best for everybody so sharing is
because we care we care that's why we
share so we're trying to share this
beautiful way of life with the world now
some might say well you know I'll act
one way with with them but now I'm going
to be mean to the others those that
aren't in Islam we have to be kind and
generous and good with with everybody is
this right definitely because this is
something that the most high the creator
of the heavens and the earth ordered us
and one of the verses of the Quran says
were cool in SE hostnet speak to people
people in general with goodness it's not
the same Muslims not so general
everybody speak to everybody with
goodness and sometimes you might be
tough on your children for example this
is goodness why because you want them to
understand something and you want them
to receive a certain message especially
if a person is in the field of Dawa and
calling people to the truth he needs to
be the most kind and the most lenient
not that he wants to deceive people but
he wants to
above these types of barriers between
him and them to see the truth he cares
about them so we need to have these
types of mannerism that needs patient
yeah right with the neighbor has a right
on us right the those who we meet in our
life the more the Muslim is whenever
someone is physically close to you he
has a right on you and the right of you
that at least he does not receive any
harm from you yeah this is something
that the prophets are seldom said when
he kept counting the things of good
things that a person can do even lifting
something on someone's mount someone in
his car and you helped him to carry a
bag to put it in the car this is not
just out of the goodness of yourself
this is the order in their religion
revelation came from the seventh heaven
to the human beings to do this simple
act for the sake of allah subhana allah
and if people would do this is that
they're for filling the orders of Allah
soprano time when he said in this
counting these types of good deeds the
least of it that nobody has an excuse in
it it the Prophet SAW Salem said that
people should not be harmed by you this
is charity yeah when people do not
receive any harm from you then this is a
charity this is a good deed this is good
mannerism and nobody would say I don't I
cannot help myself by positively being
something meat of course not stay away
from harming others this is the least
that a person can do this is amazing and
Islam we know is the fastest-growing way
of life in the world today yesterday and
tomorrow and if we would be implementing
it the right way they would only be even
growing fasting I know we don't
appreciate it many of us that's why
we're here and we hope that everyone has
a sincere open heart open mind and they
get to benefit from this important
knowledge now tell us we're trying to
give some practical examples you know
again some people coming over from
geliyo we were there yesterday we're
coming here today and you know you
around the brother and you know you
didn't know he spoke another language
we're speaking English but then he turns
the corner and he speaking French and
I'm not talking french fries or French
fruit I'm talking about you know words I
shouldn't be coming out of a person's
mind is this good mannerisms swearing
cursing can I must
be doing this of course not and why
because a lot of the most high for betas
and their surah in the Quran that talks
about this and mannerism do not mock one
another do not call each other names and
when a person knows that this is from
his creator then the submission is
different because if it's not from the
Creator people would deal with one
another as rewarding one another or just
trying to get some benefits but we don't
do that for the benefit of a human being
we're doing that because we need to be
obedient to allah span of time so the
issue of people when they come into the
message it or coming to islam and
there's so much jelly or ignorance they
come with they need to take care of
themselves it takes time takes time it
takes time with building the email
building the faith that what really
becomes the ground for good mannerism
not that be kind do this and do that if
the person's heart is not full of the
belief and the faith and knowing a lot
the most high with these names and
attributes and building this amend for
filling the obligations of allah
disorder and so on then it becomes just
not too much of an important attitude
that a person would have unless he would
do that for the sake of allah spinal
talent so that mouth that we use the
tongue to praise the crater we should
never curse with it right that's
definitely true this tongue isn't a
trust that we have to use it in the
proper way definitely wouldn't take a
break we right back with more here on
Today Show I just want to say very
simple message is the main Tina one of
the beautiful things about our religion
of Islam is the emphasis on direct
ritual and prayer gone directly there is
no intermediary the lights will go on
after the party and the party will end
it's very simple and very clear there
are no superstitious rituals no strange
incantations the time is running out and
you might not make it till tomorrow and
this is something that we need to think
back here on the Dean show with sheikh
ibrahim sedan people to watch more of
your shows can go to the Dean show calm
you have your own special section and
alhamdulillah think the Creator all
things to him that you are here with us
so we can benefit from your knowledge so
it seems like Islam that called to
acquire peace by submitting to your will
to the to the owner of he's the one guy
the same God of Jesus Moses Abraham Noah
that same guy that they call the people
to worship we're talking about him the
last in fundamental sent to mankind
apart Muhammad peace be upon him it
seems like this is a comprehensive way
of like nothing's left out everything
how we worship the crater how we deal
with our neighbors etiquettes with our
wives children everything is there
everything is there everything saved and
it's not again opinions it's text this
is not your opinion what you just made
up that's right it's all from the Quran
the verses of the Quran and the sayings
of the Prophet peace be upon him and
that's what people need to learn and
need to have the patience to apply it
even if people are not understanding
this they're not in the same page with
you you still supposed to be of the best
mannerism because you're doing that
because you're nothing but a servant of
Allah and he ordered you to do certain
things in the certain a certain way tell
us doesn't this reflect bad on the dour
on your call to invite people to reflect
about their purpose of life why they're
here but now you're acting like a clown
like a fool you're not implementing
Islam and now you end up being just you
know you end up being a hindrance
because isn't it like you go ahead and
and and you live one way in front of
let's say the brothers our sister is in
the mush you but you go out here you
acting foolish you're not implementing
Islam doesn't is now confuse people say
you don't want me to come to Islam
weren't you at the night club the other
day don't you treat people
disrespectfully what do I have to gain
by following Islam because you've been a
bad example right and this is exactly
what the Prophet peace be upon me said
that some of you are gonna fit in
meaning some of you are repellent
subhanim and make people run away from
seeing the truth which is another evil
that we might fall in without knowing so
we have to have that responsibility if
you say that i'm a muslim
with a responsibility that you have a
message on the face of it you don't have
to be talking to people calling them
it's your action and your conduct when
it's time for the prayer and you leave
everything even if it's a million-dollar
you leave it to obey the orders of a lot
to pray the same thing you deal with
them you buy and sell your truthful
you're doing the things that you're
supposed to do because you're nothing
but an obedient slave to a lot Hannah
Tyler that by itself is the image that
we need to do not just to get people in
but because this is the order of a loss
panel that will be asked about it in the
div judge tell us now before we come to
an end it just came to my mind that a
person is it true he can be fasting and
praying and doing all these ritual
things but now on the other end he
doesn't have good ethics morals manners
and now in the day of judgment is going
to be taken from his good deeds he was
backed by you he was doing a lot of
hideous things isn't this this is the
hadith this is a single top of the
Prophet peace be upon him that he asked
his companions one day he said do you
know who's the bankrupt among by oh my
mama dead broke dead broke they said the
one that doesn't have money so the
Prophet peace be upon him correcting
their understanding and this is what we
correct our understanding when we go
back to the Quran anism he told them the
bankrupt the broke among my oma is the
one that comes in the day of judgment
with prayers with fasting with all kinds
of good deeds but he came and he had
cursed so-and-so and he had attacked the
honor and so on so he had physically
attacked someone Wow so these people
come in the day of judgment and they
would take from his good deeds and they
would put it on to them so they would
take it from him till he has no more
good deeds because the balance in the
day of judgment good deeds or his bad
deeds and still he has some things in
his account that he abused others and so
on and still he does not have any good
deeds they would take from their own bad
deeds and they put it on him and he will
end up being thrown into the whole fight
this is a man that came thinking that
he's an agenda straight to paradise but
he ends up being in the Hellfire becomes
in his record since that he didn't do
and a lot is the most just but because
of this transgression that he
transgressed the bounds and the limits
and attacked others by word of mouth by
physically attacking them
that would bring the sins on him and
they would come into they're just gonna
take from him bad manners bad manners so
this is very very emphasized in Islam
keeping your promises of course being a
person of your word and this is the
signs of hypocrisy if a person doesn't
the prophet prophet peace be upon him
and he said the sign of a hypocrite is
three they don't even whenever he
promises he breaks his promise whenever
he speaks he lines whenever he quarreled
someone someone he is beyond the
mannerism that means he abuses so much
the quarrelsome with others which is
basically bad mannerism signs of
hypocrisy that negates the belief and
the attitude of a believer that makes
the believe deficient and that means the
relationship between mannerism and
belief it's not belief is not just
something in the heart belief amen and
Islamic belief is something done by the
heart something that said by the tongue
and something done by the whole parts of
the body it's all faith it's all belief
that increases and decreases closing
comments and suggestions for those who
are struggling they want to do the right
thing you know and they're trying to get
back past some of their bad behavior
from the past they love this because
it's increasing their Iman and this is
getting more into Islam that just needs
some more advice give it to him leather
if there's one advice that I can say in
in seconds turn to Allah the creator of
the heavens and the earth alone
sincerely truthfully that as if you are
drowning and you seek help you won't
seek help from a human being when you're
drowning and there's nothing around you
know means you would turn sincerely to
the creator of the heavens and earth
turn to him with that same attitude that
he would help you to be steadfast on the
truth that would make you see the truth
and make you among those who had the
best mannerism if we do that truthfully
we'll take the proper means and will
seek the proper means from the Quran and
the Sunnah of the Prophet SAW sullen
putting our trust in Allah subhana Allah
and learning and acting learning and
acting they go together they don't
separate from one another and this is
what we need to do mannerism is
something that we need to learn we don't
know it by default we need to learn it
according to the way of Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him and one last thing is
for Muslims and non-muslims the basic
human right if we need to correct the
understanding of what human rights is
the basic human right people need to
know about
this is the right of every human being
on the face of earth that people don't
make barriers between them and between
knowing the true message of a list and
this is their right and we need to
fulfill that right to others and to be
in their service to get them to know the
pure message of Allah thank you so much
I'm a the one guy the same God of
Abraham Moses Noah and the last the
final messenger sent to man counterpart
Muhammad peace behind me he rewards you
the one God who created man and woman
but he's not a man or woman the one guy
look look chuckle hi thank you very much
thank you thank you and we keep saying
on every show because this is the
foundation and you cannot build a house
on a weak foundation is that you submit
to the call to worship the One God and
no buts as if after that not 3 & 1 1 & 3
4 & 5 6 just one leave it alone a child
can understand that and then we need to
perfect our mannerisms our etiquettes
how we conduct ourselves with the
Muslims and the not yet Muslims we have
to be the best of examples and how you
going to do that finally your own whims
and desires know you got to submit to
the one who created you and he sent down
the verbatim word of God which is the
Quran and we have the last and final
messenger sent the man kinda problem and
peace be upon him his way his example
the authentic hadith the same way if you
were living during the time of Moses it
was the same message obey the messenger
that was sent worship the One God and
obey the messenger and this is the last
and final mr. sandman kind of problem
harm peace be upon him and we hope that
you've got to benefit and we'll see you
next time god one inshallah till that
peace be unto you
oh he created the universe to him along
the heavens and the earth l11 he is the
first he's the owner Murthy Ethan his
messengers to all his creatures of the
great danger Oh worshipping Allah then
Allah there is none greater
the Creator